[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka mr. marvel and
this is the channel where we explain it
so you don't have to do fans are still
scratching their heads over the many
events that happen in Avengers endgame
so I thought I'd put together a video
explaining everything you need to know
about how the timeline and parallel
universes in the film operate throughout
this video we'll be breaking down the
things as they happen to give you a
rough idea of how everything tied up by
the finale and how Captain America was
able to appear to Sam and Bucky at the
end of the film even though he was in an
alternate timeline Marvel mega fan Aaron
Bell has created an amazing interactive
map that showcases the journey that the
heroes went on in the movie in an
easy-to-understand fashion and if you'd
like to follow along with this video
I'll leave it linked in the description
below this is full spoilers ahead so if
you're one of the two people that
haven't seen Avengers and game yet and
don't want anything room for yourself
then I highly recommend that you turn
off now without the way I just want to
give a huge thank you for clicking this
video I hope you enjoy it now sit back
relax and let's get into my timeline
breakdown so the movie opens three weeks
after Thanos carry out the snap the
universe is devastated but after the
surviving Avengers track him down and
Thor finally goes for the head we pick
up with them five years down the line in
2023 which is where things start to get
a bit confusing due to the discovery of
time travel we start off with our heroes
all in the same position at the quantum
tunnels they have split into groups all
with their own objectives and we
initially follow team a made up of
Captain America Iron Man ant-man and
Hulk this group travels to the Battle of
New York to retrieve three Infinity
stones and split off into their own
smaller groups this part of the film is
set during 2012 and it's pretty much the
moment that the entire infinity stone
saga began with Thanos appearing in the
post-credits scene of The Avengers to
kick everything off however things don't
play out exactly as expected and it's at
this point that Loki takes the tesseract
and travels off to Disney Plus
us creating an alternate timeline Hulk
and ant-man gain the time and mine stone
and together they traveled back to 2023
however Tony and cap still need to
secure the tesseract and from here they
travel through the 1970s to get it we
will call this group team AAA and Hulk
and ant-man team a B but what happened
to the timeline they just left well
that's the timeline Rolly screwed up for
the moment and at this point
Daanish would probably still get all of
the stones and carry out the snap in
addition to this the timeline that
they've just left is slightly altered
with the stones missing and now Tony
managed to get some stuff off his chest
he still after timeline very vulnerable
team be made up of war machine nebula
Hawkeye in Black Widow then traveled to
2014 during the events of guardians of
the galaxy this team then split into
team B a and Team B B with Team B a made
up of war machine and nebula securing
the power stone from Iraq on Boromir we
joined team BB and Black Widow
sacrifices herself in order for Hawkeye
to gain the soul stone and he travels
back to the present Rhodey returns to
2023 with the Power Stone but nebula is
kidnapped and replaced with evil nebula
who's carrying out the bidding of Thanos
we will call this team made up of
thanasis forces Team B see the timeline
is really messed up now - with the
events of guardians of the galaxy not
happening as quill is enabled together
Power Stone and the Gamora from this
universe travels with Dan Oster 2023 to
fight the Avengers which I'll get into
later before we go into what happens to
team B C let's go to Team C made up
rocket and Thor they travel to Asgard in
2013 to retrieve the reality stone along
the way Thor takes muniya and together
the to journey back to 2023 at this
point this timeline is pretty messed up
with Thor dying during the events of
thought the dark world due to not having
his hammer and thus the convergence is
able to be carried out by the Dark Elves
making them the rulers of the universe
and therefore Thanos could not carry out
the snap we now go to team BC in which
evil nebula journeys back to 2023 she
pulls through the rest of team BC at
this point and they to arrive in the
now everyone is in 2023 which is where
Tony carries out the snap that killed
Stannis and its forces evil Nebula is
murdered by nebula from the present and
Gamora stays in the timeline Tony dies
at the end and from here on out the
stones pass over to Captain America who
along with Melia travels back placing
them in their correct timelines after
jumping between alternate realities
without creating new branch realities
catching up with Red Skull and replacing
all of the stones in their original
places he finally returns to Peggy for
that dance in 1950 in timeline a that
team a traveled to tap interacted with
Hydra possibly interfering with the
events of Winter Soldier and Loki
escaped it is still likely that Thanos
got all of the stones where the snap
would play out very differently with the
god of mischief potentially not dying in
timeline be that team V traveled to
Gamora is absent
therefore Drax would have never met
quill and rocket without Kimora being
assaulted in the prison the prison
breakout would only be performed by
quill rocket and Groot rocket and Groot
would link quill behind when he goes to
get his cassette player and nurse quill
stays in jail and Ronan gets the Power
Stone from him when he waits in prison
all self Dallas is now absent from this
timeline greatly upsetting the political
balance of the universe and thus Ronan
probably becomes the one that tries to
get one of the Infinity stones in
timeline see when the reality stone and
ammonia are returned to this timeline
events play out the same way that they
would have in prime reality thus this
reality has its own snap its own time
travel and its own branch timelines
these branches have their own branches
on and on into infinite fractals in
timeline a a made up of cap an Iron Man
when the tesseract is returned to this
events play out the same way they would
have in prime reality and similar to
timeline see this leads to infinite
branching timelines Captain America then
grows old with Peggy Carter and as he
still has super soldier serum coursing
through his veins cap our lives here and
this survives until 2020
three now this is where the film gets
slightly more confusing with Sam seeing
Captain America on the bench at the end
since cap doesn't return through the
machine we can conclude that he never
returns to his old reality the cap
sitting on the bench is not the cat that
we just saw traveling back in time
rather the cap on the fringes from
another branch reality that had similar
events play out in which another Captain
America travelled to this universe to
live out the rest of his days with Peggy
Carter Peggy's husband was always
alluded to but never properly shown so
we can guess and this was deliberately
done by the character so that he would
not interfere with events further and
thus create multiple realities this
explains why when cap goes to visit
Peggy in the nursing home that she says
you look so young as she would still
clasp him as an older man
well stre may never see our cap again
it's good to know that somewhere out
there he's living the life he always
wanted with Peggy and this ending will
definitely bring a tear to most people's
eyes obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts on the timeline and hopefully
this has cleared things up if you're
still stumped make sure you comment
below with your questions and if you
love this video 3,000 then please give
it a thumbs up as it took a lot of work
I my notes on this absolutely ridiculous
so I massively appreciate the like make
sure you check out my breakdown on the
x-men film franchise timeline which
would be linked at the end this is a
channel for people who are super into
superheroes so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition even the best and
I'll see you next time take care peace
[Music]
[Music]